good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today
his SCP 872 object class safe special
containment procedures when not under
controlled observation SCP 872 is to be
kept in cold storage at sector SCP 872
is to be kept two kilometers from any
concentrated group of animals considered
livestock at all times when under
controlled observation a perimeter is to
be established outside the observation
area and research is to cease
immediately in the event of an attempted
containment bridge ten members of
security are to be present during
controlled observation to enforce this
controlled observation must be approved
by one member of level 4 personnel
description SCP 872 is an aged scarecrow
outfitted with a tattered coat and hat
measuring 3 meters tall and 10
centimeters wide SCP 872 is composed of
pine wood splinters of which have not
displayed its anomalous properties when
animals considered livestock sheep's
cows chickens etc enter the area within
1.5 kilometers of scp-871 ominous
properties SCP 872 affected animals are
extremely hostile to humans and will
viciously assault any who approach them
affected animals have been observed to
utilize advanced maneuvers such as
flanking and ambushing affected animals
have also been observed to behave as if
in an automated farm environment
chickens will lay their eggs in easy to
access areas sheep will attempt to
remove wool from each other using their
teeth cows have been observed to kill
one cow each week and roughly separate
its carcass into strips of meat
each month the animals will transport
anything produced to the perimeter of
scp-871 fluence and allow humans to
remove it from the area when removed
from a cp8 72s area of influence
affected animals immediately enter a
vegetative state
this vegetative state is reversed when
said animals are returned into a CPH 72s
area of inflows okay this was a short
one today folks but I have longer
lectures planned in the future which I'm
sure you're all ecstatic about anyway
thank you all for listening and you are
all dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to Pierce M Hamlin Muslim
Mookie slump God dr. day John Oh quarter
captain Gorge fluffy sky key mana moon a
my archive curator Nick tie verbal OD
tench cheese whip I'm Depp's McGee thank
you all so much for your support I
really appreciate it if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos on some other cool stuff as
well as at patreon.com forward slash the
vulcan thank you
[Music]
you